هذا هو المختبر الذي حبس العالم مؤخرا
انفاسه تلصص لما يحدث بداخله حيث انه يتم
جلب عينات من مواقع الاسلحه الكيماويه الى
هنا صممت حاويه النقل حتى تكون مقاومه لاي
تحطم
طائره نحن نتاكد من ان تلك الاخطام صحيحه
تماما ولم يتم العبث بها ومن ثم نقوم
بالعمليه يتم تحليل العين في جهاز يطلق
عليه كروماتوجرافي الغاز وهو جهاز يحلل
ابسط المكونات والجسيمات ومن ثم يتم
التعرف على المواد
الكيماويه تحليل جي سي ام اس الروتين
للعينات البيئيه يكشف عن المكونات في اقل
من جزء في المليون وبامكانه الكشف حتى عن
العينات التي مضى على العثور عليها اسابيع
وحتى شهور تحت تهديد الضربات الامريكيه
ومع الضغوط الدبلوماسيه الروسيه وافق بشار
الاسد من حيث المبدا على وضع الاسلحه
الكيماويه سوريا تحت الرقابه الدوليه قد
تمسك منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيماويه الان
بزمام الامور في عمليه رصد المخزونات
وتنظيمها او تدميرها فقد سبق ان قامت بذلك
في بلدان اخرى وهم يعرفون الزمن الذي
تستغرقه
العمليه ذهاب المفتشين للفهرسه يعني تسجيل
عدد القذائف المدفعيه والنظر في حاويات
التخزين انه عمل شاق وعليهم عمل الكثير
ففه استها تتوقف على عدد المواقع والذخائر
المختلفه ويمكن للامر ان يست
شهورا